foreign
California
[Music]
Watts tell me about your family growing
up you had Mom and Dad yes I do I have a
biological mother and father that was
present in my life oh really yeah they
still alive to this day
I love them both dearly you know what I
mean they both Priceless but I had a
pretty rough upbring still you know
well um we always came from a household
of order you know I'm saying we were
disciplined for the right and wrong
things that just said my father was a
little excessive with his discipline you
know he didn't he kind of like wanted
didn't stop until you got the point you
know and he uh in case his last women's
week he drew blood you know what I mean
you can stop Tilly saying blood so some
disciplines were a little bit excessive
you know what I mean
how'd that affect you well at first it
had me uh I was confused a little bit
you know I I grew up a long time
thinking that fear was respect you know
what I mean if someone didn't fear me
then they didn't respect me you know
what I mean but the streets
later on in life end up you know
teaching me the opposite you know
the opposite so you joined the gang yes
at what age I like 13. 13 14 years old
that's when I got initiated in and um
your blood yeah I'm a blood from out of
uh Nixon Gardens
yeah and there's Nicholson Gardens of it
yeah the projects a bunch of people from
there yeah yeah my channel that's my
favorite uh favorite team man
but uh and then you know the streets
like I said they disciplined me and
showed me that you know it wasn't
respect it's given and the respect is
earned you know what I mean
how far are you in school
um I'm 12th grade you did yeah I went to
go I graduated yeah
you didn't uh jail in prison yeah I did
uh nine years nine years nine years
straight Upstate for a strong one
robbery it was supposed to be six years
after six years I was supposed to do
five years in one month I ended up doing
the whole six plus an additional three
yeah
I went to jail in jail
how old you know I'm 32. 32. what are
you doing with your life now
pretty much I might be honest with you
I'm trying to I call myself getting used
to society
still you know even though I've been out
for about four years I still yeah I'm
not used to institutionalized yes when I
was locked up I was living but now that
I'm living I'm locked up and I told
people you don't have to necessarily be
in prison to be doing time you know
um I find it a little hard sometime to
socialize or even get along meet people
you know
my lifestyle or or certain circumstances
is just or them not knowing me it's just
sometimes hard for people who seems to
meet me or me to meet them you know
when I want to meet him the most
you think all the tattoos yeah
everybody they judge you right from the
get-go exactly
and then some of the things I'm not a
fool but I guess I was up under a rock
because some things they may bring up on
me I'm unaware of man it's like the
first time I heard of it or
like
wow you know
what's your biggest regret my biggest
regret is uh
sometimes joining the gang I didn't need
it you know what I'm saying I learned
through I lived enough and long enough
to see that I didn't need it my life
would have been a little bit easier man
I could have put a lot of energy
elsewhere what what makes a young man
join a gang at their team well I could
say
disco the the things that were going on
in the times when I grew up
um
just a lot of [__] that we have to
encounter you know getting jumped
getting banged on you know uh
you create a lot of anger you know what
I'm saying we already have repressed
Anger from daily things we had to go
through in the neighborhood but to deal
with that with your own peoples you know
I'm saying on top of that bothering you
know what I'm saying yeah your dad made
it tough at home but then is there peer
pressure for you to join a gang yes
always yeah every every neighborhood we
stayed in there was pressure to John
they gang they turf and uh we grew up in
a lot of [__] neighborhoods and uh I
didn't like it you know I had to do is
when we go to the grocery stores my
father's age banging on me and I
couldn't stand that [__] you know he
always they always try to make us feel
like we were lesser than because we
weren't from their night and until we
were from that game we would be somebody
you know and uh I just hate to just to
you know the aggressive behavior that we
had to deal with you know I'm saying
until we were able to move from over
there and after so many times of going
through this you know it made me despise
them guys you know
um so I started I really didn't like the
crib I didn't say no Crips like that
yeah the Crips and bloods yeah always
bumping heads down there aren't they did
you ever get out of South Central on the
Watts never never saw it did you ever
see the ocean I know I did yeah I did
see the ocean probably like once or
twice you know really yeah I had to go
out since I got out and um
you know the hottest thing happened to
me man when I went to the beach you know
I I expected me to be looking at the
ladies or having this you know awesome
time but
honestly I didn't like I had a it was
difficult for me I I I I ended up crying
to myself
and it was like damn it's because you
know I never for many reasons but my to
my side
tears falling from my eyes and I
couldn't understand why I was my body
was even having that experience reaction
to it you know what do you think that
was all about I don't know I think I
don't know
sometimes I think you're a cup over full
sometimes you know it spills when they
want to you know was it was it fear was
it uh no it was it was it was anxiety
I think it was or just realizing that
you you missed out on all of this yes
yeah
like I couldn't believe it like you know
it was I was real I'm home I'm free how
old were you when you saw the beach I
was about
14.
but I've never really been outside of
Los Angeles you know like that at all
you know I never been to know the states
there's a whole world out there yeah
what do you want to do now wow
now a lot of houses I don't have my
heart broken down there I don't know
what I want
um I really always wanna
travel a little bit get to see something
else you know and um
that's it I don't want no kids I don't
want anything you know nothing you have
no kids no
no
what's the craziest thing you got
involved in with the gangs and all that
um I always have some violence right
yeah I'm gonna say uh
oh he had jumped this older guy you know
the Zelda guy you know he'll jump
uh he's got a little he was a little old
too old for my liking you know I
wouldn't have really bothered him per se
but yeah you know he was wearing he was
he was doing all the things man he
shouldn't do you know what I mean and
wearing all the things he shouldn't wear
and he kind of didn't respond to as the
way we thought he would so you know we
had to uh
you know break him in and let him know
you know that that fat means greasy you
can't you can't get away with that over
here
and um I probably would have spared to
do you know but because he's like I said
he was older you know they don't there's
no statues and limitations to age with
this you know uh we had to hit him you
know when um when my homie hit him you
know what I'm saying the dude became
unconscious
I kind of like uh I kind of stood over
him for a minute before I swung on him
and I was like man this you know this
could be my pops laying here you know I
mean I didn't want to kill him but I'm
saying but I still wanted to show the
game you know that I was a part of it
you know what I mean I meant I meant
everything they meant so I swung on them
too you know what I mean yeah man
and um
dude was all right luckily he didn't die
but you know I just gained a
I don't know a sense of myself within
myself you know I learned like next time
I won't be so fearful to speak my mind
the next time I wouldn't bother somebody
else if I felt like that I'll make sure
I said it like that you know you seem to
be a little different than most of the
gang members where you seem to realize
what you're you are doing what you were
doing yeah I was aware of it I had my
ass whoops I kind of wasn't wearing
whoopings
and I was getting them or received
giving them
that peer pressure gets you into stuff
you regret later yeah it sure does you
lost friends yeah I lost it I lost two
men
I'm a prisoner death or both both
I lost them I mean all of them really
damn near all of them but what is it
that makes a you were 13 13. what makes
a 13 year old do all that crazy [__] not
having the
um
not having a
let me say at home I guess I feared my
father and my father should come home I
didn't see it look at him like oh my
Dad's here or oh my dad you know we
haven't had the happy emotion that some
children may have when they have when
they had if I was afraid I was deeply
afraid and I was afraid of everything I
may have didn't do because I was gonna I
know the ass whooping and discipline
that was coming behind it so because uh
I grew up in fear you know so long and
really have no happy upbringing it just
we were we were in jail before I ever
went to jail I couldn't even leave off
my porch I couldn't have no females come
over it was just like real black and
white it was like oh too old school too
straight you know and uh I guess in the
in the long run it paid off because who
would have knew the cars we would deal
later on in our life and uh it helped me
Ace many things that I thought most men
couldn't get through and helped me get
through I gave me enough steel to get
through the discipline and the rough the
rough-handedness that comes with prison
you know I mean I was able to survive
and not only survive I was able to
become I was able to
become like King you know and it's in my
own way and then in a world of uh
turmoil
you know help me help me in ways he
probably could never understand help me
I told him you had sons that became like
we were
I was on I say made for it but like
he made a damn near indestructible
you know with the violence he put on us
you know it paid off I was able to get
through it what's your right what's your
relationship like now with your dad it's
excellent he's a changed man you know
yes a long time I wanted to kill my
father you know what I mean I should
sleep with knives under my pillow
um and I don't even know I wasn't aware
I was doing until my mother used to
complain about all her knives missing
and when we used to do this spring
cleaning he used to call you know we
find all the knives in my room and she
should say something why you have so
many knives in your room and I never
could tell her you know in my heart that
Mom you know I was tired of my father
kicking my ass like this that hey man
one day I planned on making sure his ass
didn't hit me again you know and I was
gonna stab him if I had to but I knew I
had one time to swing at one time if I
didn't swing and kill him the way I
thought I would in my mind he was going
to kill me so um I used to work out a
lot you know my pop said one thing to me
he had me laugh to this day he said hey
man I'm not worried about how big you
get he said you see this he said I got
he said along with this this finger my
trigger finger worker he said I ain't
worried about none of y'all I got a
bullet with your nigga's name on the
back
I laugh at it now when I was to say pops
you don't tell your kids no [__] like
that man you know what is it the change
in your death huh what is it that
changed I think it's God it's no it's
nothing it can't be nothing short of him
because it's a miracle that's the most
violent man I've ever known in my
lifetime you know I love him because I
respect his his reasoning for it it was
just that was a little you just want you
guys to straighten out that's it he just
wanted to at least the minimum we get in
school he'll take it he accepted C
um but he wanted us basically go to work
go to school you know don't never leave
your mother watch your mouth you know
respectful jobs yeah he taught his order
what jobs have you had I had a Krispy
Kreme I worked at Wendy's I worked at a
McDonald's before and I worked at the
cleaning service yeah yeah for tidy tidy
cleaning sir
and drugs are part of your life Yeah man
they part of my everyday lately
um since I got out I'm having a
a hard time coping with Society
um there's no therapy that I've been
going to there's nothing that like legal
you know what I'm saying or something
that would make sense to help me so I I
went to my uh I went to my own
medication you know in a weird way and
then yeah and it was poison I said how
the hell poison become my medicine in
these times you know but yet I found
myself using it something that I despise
and seen to tear others down around with
this start for you it started actually
be in prison a little bit like towards
the end of my sentence you know I
endorse a little bit and uh you know I
didn't want to spend too I didn't have
money like that so I didn't spend my
money in there like that on no drugs but
uh when I got out because it's more easy
to you know get to
um I found myself I guess with a lot of
situations I was going through or been
going through um even homelessness man
it was like I used it as a coping
mechanism you know I I you start using
the drugs and I start sniffing
and uh I hate it though because it tore
me down you know I used to be so big
when I got out I was I was way bigger
than what I am really yeah man mentally
and physically you know but um I love
that to you know have his wear and tear
on me a little bit so
I'm winning I can't wait till I get off
of it you know you've been out of prison
for how long now four years four years
yeah and you've been struggling and I've
been using it here for four years
through my heart my hardship with my
woman you know the relationship issues
our infidelity I little things like that
I use that to help me numb and cope with
what I felt like I physically couldn't
take you know what I'm saying I didn't
want to
you know end up putting myself back up
in there for life you know for some of
the things that I've seen so far you
know even with some of my homies just to
just a disrespectful things and things
you may encounter in these times you
know I wasn't necessarily ready for it
you know me being locked up so long I
got a gut reaction towards a lot of
things man do you think prison
is you know
is there any rehabilitation in prison or
is it just yes how hell yeah it is all
the way around the board I knew from the
first year I was in there I didn't want
to go back it wasn't for me and no
matter how big I get in here no matter
how many fights I have in here how many
[__] I stab you know I don't need to
be here I don't want to be here this is
not what I was made to be here for you
know um so you're doing things now to
make sure you don't go back for sure at
least think about it I did long enough
to make sure I think about a lot of
things before I do it but unfortunately
when it comes to myself I don't use my
best judgment I'm using I'm so careless
I'm trying to teach a long time I have
to tell myself not to give a [__]
because it was beautiful it was
necessary for me in there you know to
get through my time but now that I'm out
here and I see that you need to give a
[__] at least per se just a little bit
for yourself I have a hard time teaching
myself to give a [__] you know what I'm
saying and took care for myself because
I need myself like I never needed me
before
yeah prison prison is just it's such a
racial yeah it makes it very racial even
if you ain't racist it's gonna make you
racist it's gonna make you racist at
least to where you're aware of what
races is and you know whether you're a
blood or a [__] you end up being yeah
kind of in the same gang when you're in
prison right no no if you're a crib your
crib your blood your blood you're gonna
stay that way what prison were you in I
was in high desert I did Corcoran I did
Ironwood I did CMC California men's
colony and
and that was it yeah but I've heard that
prison is you know the Mexicans the
Mexicans and the blacks of the blacks
and the yeah exactly apples would think
what they call the whites the uh Woods
the woods yeah I like that she was It
was kind of you know different but I
respect them I like the skin good I
learned one thing about me and some of
them skin the white woods they just as
nice as me
the whites are always like skinheads
right yeah with the [__] though some of
my name with the [__] man I learned
to give me I learned respect though I
learned some I learned about different
like different races and they you know
they culture a little bit more than ever
I learned to respect them in the ways
they need they should be
where'd you have to see yourself in five
years
five years I would love to see myself
owning my own business living in my own
home
um fighting pretty much alone you know I
may have me a decent young lady that I
hopefully grown with you know what I'm
saying but if not I'm alone I see myself
happy and alone do you have any friends
not really I would like to there's a few
people that I've called from I thought
with my friends since I've been out but
I learned else otherwise and it's okay
you know I'm not learning they just stay
chapter with my stories over yeah it's
amazing how many of the men and women
that I've talked to that are on the
streets that
claim they don't really have any friends
no and I think it's in these times it's
beautiful not to because a lot of times
you can get upset if something you learn
a lot of people not your friend and then
some of the friends I have the the very
few
you know um are like family they're more
than like family they the family for me
in these times the way my own family
won't be for me when I needed them the
most you know I learned their family
just not it doesn't
it's not just a home term you know what
I mean family can be through friends and
others you know what I'm saying that our
family or they're related the way they
act by the gesture
I think I asked you this before but I'm
not sure you answered it what was it
that changed in your dad that he's such
a difference everything you know his his
reaction the way he's always or was it
like you know religion or was it drugs
that he stopped or anything like that it
was it wasn't religion because he always
taught us to believe in God but
maybe just aged
I don't know what it was man I ain't
gonna lie to you I I think it was
America but he's cool now yeah I'm
talking about he's an excellent father
me and him at a you couldn't break us
apart you know what I'm saying and you
know what touched me the most is that
all right I'm aware of all the anger I
used to have but when I see him you know
how
I talked to him and I let him know to
his face how you know you kind of made
me feel
and um I always you know
I said I dealt with some of the things I
dealt with my own lifetime you know
behind his reactions he apologized
he looked me in my eyes and he said you
know what son as a father I'm sorry I
probably didn't mean none of that you
know he explained that he was beat
though his upbeat his upbringing to him
his mother his mother beat him for
things he didn't have she didn't have no
right or Reason to you know he didn't
understand why he was being beat so he
said you know he beat us and blind blind
blind emotion thinking that that was the
right way you know what I'm saying but
he apologized to me he's like you know
that was something I didn't expect I had
so much heat and it took it just took
the fire out you know what I mean I
wanted to find that fire again and be
mad at him you know give an excuse but
he apologized it was it was enough it
was enough you forgave him I forgave him
yeah forgiveness is powerful yeah and we
the best we unbreakable it's nothing I
can't do I won't do it for him
um and that touches them even more to
know that I could do something or hurt
him and I won't
okay some of you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
it's basically the
uh every when you talk you teach you
listen you learn to be more patient to
be more understanding and to understand
that I do not know everything you know
to keep an open mind man you know to
keep learning and keep an open mind but
to know thyself so that I don't cross
myself or others
you know what I'm saying
all right Tyson
thank you very much for sharing your
story I wish you the best of luck out
there man thank you man I appreciate you
it's a pleasure to meet you you too
thank you